elle s'appelle enjoy phoenix elle a 25
ans elle totalise 5 millions d'abonnés
sur instagram nuit c'est just ryad 22
ans 3 millions 400 mille abonnés et l
paula locatelli 16 ans 1 million 800
mille abonnés tous les trois sont les
nouveaux outils de communication de
l'exécutif
ils ont été approchés avec d'autres par
gabriela talent porte parole du
gouvernement
objectif sensibiliser les jeunes
français sur la question de la pandémie
de kobe de 19 vous avez tous des
communautés vous êtes suivi par d'autres
jeunes vous êtes des exemples pour
d'autres jeunes et donc on a besoin de
vous pour passer ses messages
la stratégie est simple chercher les
jeunes là où ils sont c'est à dire sur
internet
dans une étude parue en 2019 médiamétrie
précise que 38% des vidéos en ligne sont
consommés par la seule tranche des 15-24
ans une démarche donc logiquement appuyé
par le président de la république
vous qui lisez ce message vous pouvez
faire quelque chose face au virus
que vous ayez 50 cent - millions
d'abonnés sur vos réseaux sociaux
votre voix votre relais peut sauver des
vies aidez nous à appeler chacun la
responsabilité nous ne surmonterons
cette deuxième vague qu'ensemble ce que
font ces youtuber instagram heures c'est
offrir une tribune aux membres du
gouvernement un genre de questions
réponses entre les deux intervenants
c'est arrivé avec gabriella talent mais
aussi avec brune poirson ancien
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique
c'est la première fois que je m'ouvre
est comme ça totalement et que tu as eu
accès absolument à tout aurait pu
regarder avec dossiers sont nombreux et
c'est son problème et je dois dire
franchement je pense que c'est important
d'avoir cette démarche est du coup vous
êtes en première ligne donc toutes les
pressions toutes les critiques et c c ou
qu'il le prenait c'est une pression en
plus c'est pas difficile à deviner sa
cape town et porte parole pour faire ce
boulot là il faut être convaincu de ce
qu'on fait ce n'est pas la première fois
que le gouvernement passe par les
influenceurs pour toucher un jeune
public
thibault in shape youtuber auprès de
huit millions d'abonnés à assurer la
communication du service national
universel vidéo qui a rapidement fait
polémique à cause de l'aspect très
promotionnelle et aux éléments de
langage utilisé par la star du web et ce
n'est pas tout pour cette vidéo et
thibaut in shape a été rémunéré plus de
20000 euros
c'est à plaisir de vous parler
aujourd'hui
dans cette vidéo vous allez découvrir
plein de choses et nous ne sommes pas
tout seul tout seul accompagné du
secrétaire d'état monsieur gabriel attal
aujourd'hui les youtuber sollicitait
sont catégoriques ils ne sont pas payés
par le gouvernement mais agissent pour
bien faire beaucoup de gens qui pensent
aussi que je suis rémunéré par l'état le
cas je peux le confirmer
voilà collabos parti-pris parodie de
science fiction
ces collaborations n'ont pas vraiment
fait l'unanimité sur la toile
dites vous pour le gouvernement un job
phoenix just ryad représente la jeunesse
ptdr attal en live avec angel phoenix
mais vraiment c'est même plus une
dystopie sco vie
c'est une mauvaise parodie de sfc qui le
porte parole du gouvernement
gabriel attal ou enjoy phoenix je
commence à avoir un doute des critiques
infondées et trop agressive selon et
mcup l influence faisons millions 900
mille abonnés sur instagram se
justifient elles aussi après un direct
avec le porte parole du gouvernement
je ne suis pas la seule à avoir pris
autant de violence parce que je ne suis
pas la seule influence euse avoir fait
de la pub
enfin fait la pub pas du tout c'est un
lapsus pardon qu'il s'agisse de
publicité ou non la méthode
a de quoi interpeller puisqu'elle permet
à la classe politique de s'exprimer sans
filtre ni contradiction devant une
audience importante
cela permet aux leaders politiques de
pose un cadre d'interprétation
particulier de commenter sa propre
action il y a ainsi une possibilité pour
ceux qui nous gouvernent d'échapper au
travail plus distanciée au filtrage plus
critique que pourrait effectuer des
journalistes il n'existe pas de bonnes
influences toute influence est immoral
c'est ce que disait oscar wilde
des paroles qui donne encore plus à
réfléchir à cette époque de puissance
numérique